Now that we've set up the fingers using a custom function, we're going to explore
an alternate setup that will use a couple of different nodes, the getChildren node and
the parent constraint node.
So instead of using a series of set and getTransform nodes, we're going to use the getChildren
node, which does exactly what it implies, it will find all of the children of a specific
reg element.
And in this case, we'll use our hand bones to find all of the finger bones below, and
again, use that information to find all of our finger controls as well.
So with our getChildren nodes, if I right click, search for getChildren, you can see
we can input a name here and essentially an item, a reg element, and it will find all
of the children of whatever we input here.
Now we do want to look for a bone, and we want to look for handL.
Now I'm going to duplicate this because we want to use, well, we want to find the bones
for both of our hands.
So if I find handR there.
Now what we want to do, just to make the logic a little bit more straightforward, is add
these two arrays together.
So if I right click and search for add under the array heading here, we'll plug the first
array in here, and then it's not add, what is it?
It is append.
So we want to append the two arrays together, which is just essentially tagging one onto
the end of the other.
So now that we have a big list of our bones underneath our hand, left and our handR.
Now something we need to activate is recursive.
What this will do is find all of the children of the hand's children.
So if I show you this as an example, under our handR, the real children are the pinky
metacarpal, the ring metacarpal, and the middle metacarpal.
So essentially the parents of our new smaller chains here.
And with recursive ticked, what that will do is search through all the way to the end
of the chain.
And making sure include parent is unticked means we won't affect the actual hand bone
itself.
Now what we want to do, something called a forEach, and this will loop through each
element of the array.
And we're going to connect our appended arrays together to this forEach.
And then we're going to create a parent constraint node.
And what we want to do here is plug in our child, which will be our bones.
And then our parent is going to come from the name of our forEach.
We'll use another concat node, underscore control.
So that means that for the end of all of our bone names here, we're going to add underscore
control.
And then inside the item of parents, we're going to drop the name in there, change that
to control.
And hopefully we should see if we connect up this logic to the main forward solve.
What I'll do here is just create a sequence just to make this a little clearer about how
this logic is working, just so we can compartmentalize things a little bit.
And what we should see now is that our finger control actually controls our bones.
So if I was to just disconnect here, just to make sure we're not seeing anything tricky,
nothing works yet.
And when we reconnect our logic back up, we can see that it works straight away.
So that's just another way to simply connect your controls with your bones.
By building all of the logic off the name of your bones, appending the two arrays together,
and then for each of the elements in the array, adding underscore control to the name so that
we can use that as our parent inside the parent constraint, and then adding the element of
the array, which is just the bone names themselves as the child of our parent constraint.